you know what I would say like the most
respectable figure like like a Barack
Obama Barack Obama yeah so weird long
pause
I heard someone else like someone have
an essay mark about know where I heard
it but like imagine the president the
United States saying like hey come over
to my house and Pasadena okay cool it's
like oh make sure you bring your kid
Kobe SEC okay cool yeah my Kobe's a big
fan it's like ah hey I'm glad you had
some good time at this dinner how about
you know you let Coby us sleepover it's
like okay it's like how baby's still in
my bed like that yeah it's like you know
they're sleeping same bit like what I
just don't I don't see it and that's
what the argument about like the whole
exploring and trying to blackmail and
like I could see from that angle but cuz
I could also see if the President of the
United States said hey while she left
your kid spend the night in the White
House and I'm like oh [ __ ] why don't my
Secret Service is everybody around here
right right I'm not thinking about like
[ __ ] everybody running the train on
my kids booty huh that's not what I'm
thinking about correct I'm just thinking
that he's gonna spend a night in one of
the presidential rooms and they're gonna
sleep in a separate bed he's gonna wake
up he'll have a presidential breakfast
right have some president presidential
luncheon crackers and have some
presidential water yeah
I'm not thinking about all that all that
other stuff but if the president said
said well let's have him sleep in my bed
then I'd be like Kobe was like hey I got
to sleep in Brock's bed hello what yeah
you slept in his bed right exactly
I'd be pissed right yeah ask questions
like some taxing like the the parents
though did have that same thing that the
r.kelly parents had oh you saw that the
CBS interview thing no was that obvious
I like a six-minute eight-minute like
they had a rebuttal like they
interviewed the parents and so like they
called the
the daughter afterwards and was like hey
this is dad or this is mom eating psycho
high and then they had I think it was a
the the one that was not talking the
most in the interview okay her low
sister jumped on the phone it was like
hey and then that kind of stalled the
sister mmm in not delivering the
expected script that she's been
delivering to her parents
yeah a time so it's kind of like a
moment for the parents a moment of hope
to make them believe that it wasn't too
late to save her daughter oh because up
to this point it was like you could feel
like I keep calling him Robert I can't
even call Mark Kelly anymore you're
Robert now bro yeah
like Robert the monster he's just right
there making sure that she's you know on
script and making it sound normal
you know even with his case like with
Robert with Robert Kelly here's his home
so you're not even you're not in you're
not even the same man yeah when a Gayle
King was interviewing him dude that [ __ ]
was wild man that bull had an emotional
breakdown you talk about a man that
could not compose himself to save his
life yeah she was just yo Gayle King was
super composed you talk about a lady
that knows what's up she was like I'm
not gonna let this guy take like take
control or like especially break me now
you don't scare me so she looked like
hmm missile this little Texas we say
this is our Kelly look like he's making
it an album hey I wasn't far off man
there's videos out now oh really yeah
people were like friggin I'll between
that [ __ ] that's like ours if I know how
to do a [ __ ] I'm viral I'm trying to
take my life yeah you can't help but
make music a yeah he was rhyming
everything T I wish I know what he said
we use rhyme here he didn't know it I
have a wife yeah you take my life I'll
kill myself with a knife I think they
did it over the [ __ ] chat with them
chat in the closet
mr. min oh god dude it's perfect
all-kill he's like super mad out of
shape - I didn't realize that yeah
kind of yeah you could tell by his pants
cuz when he stood up his dress pants had
those tiger stripes stretched out it was
i know exactly what those are excited to
get those all the time on my pants man
like his [ __ ] pants suit had those
[ __ ] sharp ridges on it something
stretched so hard was a raid wat
Wade Robinson when he was talking